nincsenek feleslegesen eltúlzott
illemszabályok nem kerekítjük sokat a
dolgokat kimondjuk amit akarunk és úgy
ahogy akarjuk mindegy hogy ki mit gondol
és mindegy ki hogyan reagálja le az
agyunkból gravitációval leesik a
gondolat és azonnal kijön a szánkon
nincs filter sok vita van a különböző
társadalmi csoportok között viszont
amikor az ország bajban van akkor az
olyan szervezettséget is egységet
mutatunk fel mint senki más a világon ez
történik most a háború alatt is van egy
szép dolog a háború árnyékában amit a
média nem mutat be mert ez nem hoz annyi
nézettséget mint a gázai képek izraelben
érezhető hogy mindenki használja a
tehetségét befolyását pénzét idejét az
ország érdekében anélkül hogy valaki
erre megkérte volna a háború első napján
a külföldön tartózkodó izraeliek
megrohanták a repülőtereket hogy gyorsan
hazajöhessenek segíteni az országot
függetlenül attól hogy behívták őket
aznap a hadseregbe vagy sem mintegy
300000 izraeli készült elhagyni az
otthonát délről és északról a hamasz és
a hezbollák támadásai miatt a
biztonságosabb részeken élő helyi
családok és hotelek pillanatok alatt
befogadták őket étteremtulajdonosok
veszik a személyzetüket viszik a
személyzetüket délre és főznek a
katonáknak ingyen fodrászok mennek
önkéntesen délre é levágják a katonák
haját zenészek mennek délre és énekelnek
a katonáknak